welcome to wired gadget challenge the
show where air congestion from Battle
Damage
test out the coolest products ripped
from the pages of Wired magazine this
week gifts that are fun on overdrive
today we are testing out three fun
gadgets for people of all ages on deck
the puzzlebox orbit helicopter little
bits electronics and first up the Sphero
Olie spin drift and flip that up to 14
miles per hour with the app controlled
Spiro Ollie for our first challenge we
built this miniature astroturf soccer
field to pit Ali versus ollie first goal
wins go I've been practicing all week
for this I'm practicing for two minutes
for this they count if I get in the back
of the goal no I think that's a penalty
that's good defense penalty kick 1 try
each penalty kick shootout see if Eric
gets this that's my turn
we have a tie if you're both were
equally bad at that the puzzlebox orbit
helicopter is operated with an EEG
headset which measures users brain waves
and sends commands to the helicopter
based on their mental attention or
relaxation all right so we're both
hooked up to the puzzlebox orbit
helicopters let's see whose copter can
hover the longest ready
what are you thinking
yes professor X my brain is exhausted
Erik's longest flight time 22 seconds
that's good
Justin's longest flight time 14 point
Eric last but not least we have little
bits a collection of 14 color-coded
modules that snap together with magnets
to make over 600,000 possible circuit
combinations so last night Eric and I
both went home with a premium set of
little bits to see who could build the
coolest thing here's how it went
I'm very intimidated Eric is the Builder
I think if I can't beat Eric and skill
alone maybe I can beat him in bribery
something alright I think I am done I
wonder how Eric's doing I think it's
about 9:30 I put this off far too long
but I have a workshop and Justin doesn't
a few hours before the night of the
shoot is not enough time all right it's
time for the big reveal
Kerry our referee is going to decide
which creation is better neither of us
have any idea what their abilities so I
built this stealth attack helicopter and
there's lights I have two minutes cool
so I made more of a like I said more of
an art piece here so president horde
this the star button all right Wow
next pull the little toggle are you
really playing to the audience something
just came out what mine's also full of
money
I think you did your best when I say
congratulations to you for your efforts
Thanks I think we have a clear winner
here yeah yeah yeah well that's it for
today's episode to learn more about any
of the products we tested here check out
the links down there in the description
and make sure and watch our other videos
in this series including our tour of the
New York wired store for more great
gadgets and gifts to make your life
better the New York wired store opens in
New York City in December and make sure
to subscribe